riew first our boy we're not in our
hands what we were doing was facing each
other from the front here instead of
putting our hands together here we're
putting them together b t we were just
checking out a range of motion seeing
let's do the winding and
unwinding winding all the way up to here
unwinding Contin uh an extension of this
that starts to teach you about how to
turn through different plane
configurations
is as we as we open up and we get to
here we're going to look towards the
camera and these hands break apart and
then we kind of face this way we could
stay here and do a couple of these just
to get used to it then we can turn our
hands come back together we come back to
this middle plane and as we turn over
toward this other red wall our other
hands come apart
so we've got this nice transition area
where we both Touch This Plane and then
the next hand comes apart so that we're
on two planes so let's let's make it go
every here we
[Music]
go pretty much the whole class is the
parner toy and so I introduced the
different stances you might find your
yourself in when in partner coil what we
worked on today we did three things we
made use of front to front today we made
use of cross stance and we also made use
of back to front or front to
back um and we Pi boy
smle we did some two beat and three beat
weave facing each other this is very
analogous to
uh what you do by yourself it's like I'm
the left half of the body he's the right
half or I he po this is an important
point because we aren't actually part of
the same body and therefore our brains
aren't actually you know intrinsically
telepathically linked we have to
communicate partner boy is all about
communication and and deciding what
roles you're going to play as you're
learning or else it can be really
confusing we both agreed okay we're
going to spin forward that way towards
the camera and we're trying to spin in
Split time and Dan has decided he's
going to be the one who initiates the
move so I'm just waiting ready for Dan
to initiate the move let's do a 2B 2B
yeah one
two I in a way I feel like the T be is
actually to keep the
timing to keep three beat three beat
starts the same way it uses one
repetition of two beat the initiator
does one two beat underneath the arm to
initiate the three beat so I initiate
two be then I initiate three
beat over under back so it's behind D
shoulder behind in shoulder
around all right sweet what we didn't do
last class with this awesome cross stce
forb thing it's actually really easy as
soon as you start to get the hang for it
it's
just feels really natural like we've
literally taught uh people in 15 minutes
how to do this who had never seen play
before we've offset ourselves it turns
out we're holding our poy in I'm holding
in my right hand he's got his in his
right hand but because we're standing
across from each other they link
up I'm going to spin my poy kind of on
this plane in front of me a little bit
behind Dan and he's doing the same with
me we've decided which direction we're
spinning so so we're our poy wheels are
rolling that way towards the
wall so to him it feels kind of like
he's spinning forwards if he's looking
at that wall and to me when I'm looking
that way it looks it feels like
backwards the easy way for Dan to
initiate this is to do a flip up over
the top hook around my arm like Dosey Do
and bring my arm back there let's go
ahead and do that flips over Dosey Do oh
my arm comes over there so that was the
first half of it now my arm wants to
come back to its wall but it's not good
enough just to go back by itself I want
to bring Dan's arm over there too so he
goes hey John come over to my wall and
say no no come back over to my wall and
if we keep repeating that it's a super
simple way to do this weave so let's do
that come over to my wall ah no you go
back to my wall no baby my time is
better you obviously haven't seen my hot
Tu
you that you
said also notice that once we get this
going we have have definitive roles as
to who Dosey Do's over the shoulder and
who Dosey Do's under Dan as the forward
spinner takes my arm in between us down
below the shoulders and I as the reverse
spinner take his arm I come around and
scoop his arm up and over notice how I'm
not like right here I'm actually I I've
given enough space so there's this tiny
little kind of diagonal cordor between
our toes so that as he spoops us through
the middle there's more space for that
to happen we're kind working on three
height levels when we're doing the arms
winding around each other thing it's
happening roughly at about shoulder
level but then there's the low hit the
golf ball transition and the high ring
the bell transition quack ding quack
ding so three levels high medium low
medium high medium low medium high
something like that front to back weave
is very much like three beat weave front
to front but the person who switches
around this way has a slightly more
confusing job at first it's going to be
the same movement and Rhythm just I got
a flip behind me now
so uh I'll I'll initiate this one either
person can so I'm going to initiate by
going under behind Dan's
back and then I go over Dan shoulder
under it back around over the shoulder
under the shoulder back back
around folding so if we're kind of
handcuffed together CU we're weaving
here I can fold out into the cross
stance and use this to transition
between different moves that we've been
learning the key is treat your POI like
the poy Blades of Doom and as Indiana
Jones you need to do the smart thing and
move when they're not in your in the
place you want to step to if I try to
step now I get hit on the other hand
if I step when my poy are getting out of
my way moving from this plane back
behind Dan I can now step there and it
turns into the cross
weave same thing if I want to step back
in front of Dan to take it to the same
position I was in I shouldn't do it when
the whole are FR of in I should do it
when they're behind in so as they go
behind him I step over here we drop a
beat we're back into the three beat went
from a four beat to a three beat so it
was kind of quick
this other transition adds a Beat from a
3 beat to a 4 beat so it's a little more
relaxed paceu is right so folding behind
we can also do that so instead of
stepping when it's behind in I want to
step when it's behind me so I get out of
the way I go he goes over and I cross
over that was the kind of quick
transition I step when I flip over Dan's
arm so I step here
[Music]
around and that's about
that all
right now go crack